اثار تصوير وملاحقه الكاميرا لجورجينا
صديقه رونالدو في كل مكان في مراكز التسوق
بالسعوديه واماكن اخرى غضبا واستهجانا
كبيرين بين السعوديين حيث اظهرت مقاطع
فيديو لجورجينا وهي تتسوق في احد المحلات
بالرياض وتشتري بعض المنتجات ما اثر
الكثيره من التفاعل بين النشاطات على
مواقع التواصل بسبب التهافت على تصويرها
[موسيقى]
لقي مقطع فيديو متداول على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي ستنكارين كبيرا لرجل امريكي قام
بريشي امراه متشرده بالماء البارد لانها
تجلس امام معرضه الفني بمدينه سان
فرانسيسكو
[موسيقى]
فجاه وزير الزراعه الرومانيه المذيعه
والضيوف بشخيره بعدما غطى في نوم عميقا
خلال حديث متلفز على الهواء مباشره حول
ازمه اوكرانيا وتداعياتها على المزارعين
في بلاده فيما لم يتمالك الضيوف في
الاستديو انفسهم من الضحك
[موسيقى]
مقطع فيديو متداول يظهر وقوع حادثه مروريه
بسبب عطل طرقه على سياره تسلا بينما كانت
تعمل في وضعيه القياده الذاتيه في احد
الانفاق بولايه كاليفورنيا
[موسيقى]
كان هذا كل شيء لليوم